oh
their appeals for help are plain to hear
many trapped in the blaze that would
soon kill 74 people at least 12 of them
children what is now a black and shell
housed hundreds of families densely
packed onto five floors the abandoned
building owned by the city was illegally
taken over by criminal gangs which
charged vulnerable people such as the
homeless to live there this is a tragic
event an incident and one that is
unprecedented given the number of of the
number of lives that that has been lost
in this in this incident we will do our
best to ensure that we act diligently in
investigating the fire and equally in
our pursuit to reclaim the hijacked and
illegally occupied buildings in the city
the Johannesburg City Council police
have been criticized for not doing
enough to stop lawlessness and extortion
by criminal gangs
some blame poor City management and slum
landlords for the disaster
City officials say there are as many as
400 hijacked or illegally occupied
buildings here many of them derelict and
not for habitation critics say poor
governance and an ongoing housing crisis
are contributing to the problem hijack
building is an easy target the Inner
City Property Owners Association says
buildings have been commandeered for 20
years and if City officials inspected
buildings as often as they should fewer
buildings would be illegally occupied a
lot of it has got to do with building
neglect and opportunity from Criminal
syndicates so
building hijackers will literally drive
around the city looking for buildings
that aren't managed property that aren't
looking good that aren't well maintained
and they will go into those buildings
because they're easy targets she says
slum landlords often use violence and
intimidation to control tenants the
lesson for us is that we've got to
address this problem
and roots and everything else root out
those criminal elements because it is
these types of buildings that are taken
over by criminals who then Levy rents on
on vulnerable people and families who
need and want accommodation in the in a
city but for the dead and those mourning
them the government's attention has come
at a high cost the middle Al Jazeera
Johannesburg
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera